how do you celebrate tonight
oh come on brother okay first of all I
have my family with made my daughter and
I have my wife and I have a lot of my
group my team no teams Roldan and the
cast of that we promised each other we
were going to have some drinks we're
gonna stay up all night I will I will
report to you next time I see you if
everyone kept to that problem I don't
want to know does everybody keep to that
problem exactly and then here's the
thing
did you fly yourself here did you play
you so you blew yourself here you'll fly
home will you strap the Emmy or we put
it up in the cockpit with you oh I'm
gonna take it with me I have to because
you know they're they're rarefied you
know how often they take home an Emmy
you know I have to Austria nominations
but there are nominations this time I
get to take home an Emmy it's nice is
there anybody you want to thank because
you think I'm very very proud of the 22
nominations and John Langford and John
Silver you're very special people but
the biggest things has to go to Ryan
Murphy because he made this all possible
and my family Kelli Ellis Ben and my
little jetty
I love you all so much there you go